you've spoken to her just in your own
words can you explain what on Earth has
been going on Sue Ella decided to seek
the advice of a trusted colleague on a
draft written ministerial statement that
was due to come out tomorrow much of it
which had been pre-briefed she sent that
unfortunately with a personal email and
that is technically a breach of the
rules she's decided to front up and say
that she's broken the rules and
therefore she must rest resign and I
want to be absolutely clear if she
hadn't made this mistake today she would
have been continuing in the government
continuing to serve as Home Secretary
it's absolutely no question of this
being an attack on the Prime Minister as
such and you know this is really
regrettable I wish she was staying and I
very much hope the Prime Minister will
feel able to bring swella back in the
new year
so she leaked a confidential government
policy paper to another Tory MP I think
some people are reporting it it's John
Hayes he let everybody know that this
was the case and then she's had to
resign because she felt it possible to
break the confidentiality of government
and
um and basically leaked some of the most
sensitive Market sensitive information
that that is in this government Sam
that's uh that's very much overplaying
it there's absolutely no question of
this being Market sensitive whatsoever
it's also Downing Street are wrong it's
a written ministerial statement in
relation to immigration so she felt that
because she'd used her personal email
and that is technically a breach of the
rules that she should go we would we
were told that it was Market sensitive
because it would have an impact on the
office for Budget responsibilities
numbers and that feeds through into
growth forecasts that's why it's Market
sensitive that's why she had to go so
you have Zoella braveman leaking Market
sensitive information I wouldn't
describe a bit as a leak I can
understand the chain of logic with the
obr there but what I would say is that
we all of us as ministers work with
colleagues on the back benches and
indeed of all parties to consult
parliaments on their opinion
parliamentarians on their opinion it's
perfectly normal to engage
parliamentarians we we do it all the
time what isn't normal is to use one's
personal email to send an official
sensitive document but as I say the
reason it was official sensitive was
because it was a draft written
ministerial statement it was going to be
laid tomorrow much of it had already
been briefed out so this is people
should not allow themselves to think
this is highly sensitive document it's a
document that's going to be public
tomorrow much of which had been briefed
so you know we we do routinely engage
with parliamentarians of all parties I
think to call it a leak is unfair uh
suela chose to to take the advice of a
trusted colleague it's a mistake as a
result she's gone now one of the big
issues between sowella bravaman and the
Prime Minister has been immigration
policy it's been a very difficult
subject for this government because of
course there were promises made in 2019
to to reduce the amount of migration
overall
do you support the 2019 Manifesto
commitment to reduce immigration as so
well it did well I of course stood on
that Manifesto but I am going to seek to
be continue as a government Minister
supporting the government what I would
say is it's very important when we do
talk about these matters that we get the
figures right so I hope when when we
look at the obr's numbers in due course
I hope those numbers will will reflect
immigration as it actually is sorry just
to pass what you're saying you sounds
like you disagree with the decision to
jump the 2019 cap that want to keep your
government job well Sam the reality is
I'm Bound by the ministerial code to
represent government policy now we have
to be realistic about migration Sue Ella
was taking a good strong line on the
boats Crossing illegally that's still
got to be dealt with and suello was
taking a good pragmatic line on the
seasonal agricultural workers scheme
which again I support and also of course
we stood on a Manifesto commitment but
it's not for me to preempt what the
prime minister's migration policy is
unclear what was in the manifesto and
I'm clear that as a government Minister
when a decision is taken as I'm required
to do Under the ministerial code I will
represent that decision another area
that is quite contentious involves a an
area that you're directly involved it is
Northern Ireland now
um it struck me today that one of your
colleagues David Jones was expecting the
prime minister to say that she would
prevent any amendments to the north line
and protocol bill that she would make
sure that she stood up to the EU in a
tough way but the premise didn't quite
give the reassurances wanted that she's
going to face down the EU is there some
concern that the Prime Minister isn't
going soft on brexit that's absolutely
not the case no and I can speak to this
obviously very directly in my role we
all want a negotiated outcome we're very
clear that we want a negotiated outcome
but to get to it we've got to have the
right atmosphere and tone to what we're
doing and to get into a negotiating
tunnel we've all got our red lines the
EU of course would prefer that we stop
the progress of the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill we need to talk about the
jurisdiction of the ecj but we we need
to really not emphasize those moments
those at the moment get into the
negotiation solve the technical problems
and then towards the end we'll deal with
our rent so she hasn't just run into a
round with the ERG no she absolutely not
she came to the ER she went to the ERG
yesterday I attended and didn't speak
but so she was very strong she enjoyed
the overwhelming support of the room
now you um are a prominent figure I
think it's fair to say on the right of
the party you're now a government
Minister and the government that you
serve in has two supporters of Rishi
sunak and two of the great officers of
state and Jeremy Huntington Now Grant
chaps and Liz truss's prime minister in
acting Rishi next policies how do you
feel about that I'm very comfortable the
conservative party has always been a
coalition of conservatives and classical
liberals like me I mean I like to think
of myself as being on the free market
left but that's for another occasion but
the point is our party is a broad church
and it should be a broad Church it
should be the broadest spectrum of the
center rights and I'm very happy to see
people in government who are talented
and can deliver for our constituents and
for the country I'm pleased and proud of
the people we have in office but a bit
of you must reflect on or maybe even
regret the enormous u-turns that have
been made over the last few days you
think growth is a big priority the
policies which resemble a bit like
austerity 2.0 coupled with big tax Rises
can't get you out of bed in the morning
but the reality is what gets me out of
bed in the morning is making sure that
we're a government and we're a party
that can deliver for the public and that
part of that delivery is being on a
trajectory to make sure that we can pay
people's pensions and health care in 20
years time but if you look at reports
from the office for Budget
responsibility the fiscal sustainability
report if you look at the National Audit
offices report into the National
Insurance Fund very boring documents but
very important we've got about 20 years
to solve a problem of growth having
enough resources to meet those
challenges and that this is why I'm so
Keen to stick by Liz truss she
understands that we have to go for
growth or we're facing Decline and
serious problems later so for the sake
getting out of bed in the morning for
the sake of normal people getting their
pensions and their health care in 20
years you can't tell me less trust isn't
a strong position though can you well
it's obviously an extremely difficult
time right now but I'm ex I'm very very
clear that this prime minister is the
one we need to stick with and in
particular in the votes later today
we've ended up with a confidence matter
on the table it's extremely important
that no one seeks to punish the
government in these votes you know this
is a very sensitive and difficult time
the best way forward for the public is
for everyone to just Row in and help
this prime minister stabilize her
government and drive forwards together